summer 22 maybe a stacked season from
the get-go sure there are no incoming
major blockbusters or anything like that
but it's in this coming season that will
get the much-awaited continuation to
devil is a part-timer and classroom of
the elite there's also sequels for
rent-a-girlfriend overlord danmachi
shadow's house maiden abyss and others
as well but that's not what we're here
for
[Music]
in this video we're here to give some
shine to the new contenders the new
shows looking to make their mark in the
anime world this is a list of what i
feel are the top 10 most anticipated new
anime this summer 2022. if you're
someone looking for something new to
watch you've come to the right place but
hey all this talks making me quite
hungry good thing i'm in luck thanks to
our sponsors for the day introducing
tokyo treat and sakurako exquisite snack
boxes from japan tokyo tree and sakurako
are two subscription-based snack boxes
that feature all sorts of japanese
treats sakurako is the one that brings
to you the authentic and artisan side of
japan and this month's theme is tea time
in yokohama a theme that will surely
take you through the sights and sounds
of japan's second largest city they're
partnering with the kanagawa government
and local snack makers to introduce
traditional yokohama delights in a
special yokohama inspired design box
yokohama gives you the best of both
worlds with awesome treats like their
signature chocolate crunch and my
personal favorite cream wafers it's also
june so you know what time it is summer
festival tokyo treat brings this anime
staple to you with its box for the month
summer matsuri tokyo treat prides itself
on providing seasonal and exclusive
japanese snacks and this month is no
exception it's a box full of the most
flavorful delicacies that summer
festivals have to offer ranging from
apple pies to a summer festival classic
yucky soba well what are you waiting for
check out the link in the description
and use code vinnie to get five dollars
off your first box there's no reason for
anyone who enjoys japanese treats to
miss this chance
first off we start with futo pi
fujo pi is a show that somewhat gives me
an old school feel set in the city of
futo the show starts the two heroes from
narumi detective agency shotaro hidati
and his partner philip the two have once
defeated the evil organization museum
before but there's no rest for the weary
as remnants of the gaia memories devices
that allow people to transform into
super powered monsters remain in the
black market with monster sightings
continuing the two resolve to get to the
bottom of the subsequent supernatural
phenomena it's the whole mystery slash
urban action feel with the superheroes
the criminal syndicates and partners in
crime with this being a sequel to the
hit live action series carmen ryder w
perhaps that much is to be expected from
what i can see so far if you're a fan of
mysteries with a few call backs to
modern heroes think something like tiger
and bunny or samurai flamenco and you'll
be in for a ride
at number nine is yakuza's guide to
babysitting
yakuza's guide to babysitting is quite
self-explanatory in terms of title it
tells of toru kirishima who conveniently
uses the job of being the crime family's
right-hand man as an excuse to let his
inner demons out nigh unstoppable thanks
to his violent nature he's earned the
intimidating nickname demon of sakuragi
except maybe for one thing you see there
are quite several things that violent
gangsters may find themselves in trouble
with one such thing is the guy's sudden
assignment taking on one of the toughest
challenges known to man babysitting is
this the start of a heartwarming story
or a disaster waiting to happen i can't
help but compare this to way of the
house husband that show may not have had
the best reception in terms of
adaptation but it did show us the often
hilarious scenario of a crime boss being
pulled from his life of crime and
violence into well more mundane things i
guess well if you found the former quite
lacking as an adaptation and trust me
many did perhaps yakuza's guide to
babysitting may be the redemptive work
that you're looking for
next up is my stepmom's daughter is my
ex
hooray for these kinds of titles my
stepmom's daughter is my ex shows off
the best of the modern light novel title
memes clickbaity spells out the premise
immediately and piques people's
interests rom-coms can be a mixed bag
overall but i'm looking forward to this
by the mere fact that i'm pretty sure
people will be watching this and it will
probably be one of the most polarizing
shows of the season the premise is what
it says in the title two lovers break up
their parents remarry and voila they're
kind of siblings now thus begins a
hilarious ride of mind games awkward
misunderstandings and lots and lots of
craziness it's certainly a rom-com with
a rare premise and i'm sure it will be
loads of fun with our two main leads
it's got the premise that's a bit of a
snark bait you know with people claiming
it's incest but from what i've heard the
source material is actually very
interesting
it's even wholesome at some point as
well so i can't wait to watch this one
following that we have uncle from
another world
[Music]
don't you love it when it seems that
some anime opens the front gate to stuff
with similar premise being adapted i
know there's no direct correlation that
can be proven and i'm positive that the
success of sword art online and attack
on titan opened the gates to a lot more
trapped in a video game and humanity
fighting a desperate war against monster
invaders anime being greenlit
respectively why did i suddenly go on
this tangent i'll get onto that in just
a while but basically uncle from another
world is about dakar for me and his
uncle who fell into a coma 17 years ago
suddenly said uncle returns now a fan of
video games uncle turns out to have been
issacied into another world and had his
own adventures as a hero it's up to
dakafumi to catch his uncle up with a
lot of the modern geek stuff like anime
tropes the internet and the ill-fated
console wars i saw my tangent a while
ago now doesn't this kind of remind you
of your boy kong ming i know i'm
clutching us draws it but i think it
would be good to help set expectations
and what we could see i think the
premise is very interesting and while i
don't see this becoming the mainstream
hit of the season it could be a fun
watch with a cult fan base
when will ayumu make his move enters to
continue the legacy of a suspiciously
similar pair of characters
if the art has included you in this is
the next work of the guy responsible for
bringing us takagi sun and the currently
airing inside tsubaki kunochi's heart
and if you know anything about these two
you know what you're in for with ayumu
diabetes but in different levels the
author just has a knack for these sweet
and awkward romances and will ayumu make
his move is no different this time the
story centers around ayumu the shogi
club's newest recruit and the club
president urushi excited to finally have
someone to play with urushi aims to be
this guy's best mentor but she can't
help but stumble on her embarrassment
not helping matters is the stone-faced
ayumu who dares make the boldest
compliment or while promising to confess
his love only after he's beaten her in
shogi will this ever happen though
that's the question through school and
shogi the two have some of the most
heartwarming and cute misadventures it's
not quite takagi-san but it sure seems
like a spiritual successor so if you're
up for a heap of sweet cute romance then
you know what to watch
and if you've been watching this video
so far i'd like to have just a little
bit of your time and ask you to hit that
like and subscribe button a lot of my
viewers still aren't subscribed so if
you do fall into that category please do
subscribe okay we're ever inching closer
right now to the million subs milestone
so come on let's hit that goal together
now shall we
off the break we continue with the third
rom-com in the list engage kiss
well well well what do we have here
original anime from a1 pictures i don't
engage kids has been built as a rom-com
based on the tags we know but with the
people involved i can't help but feel
we'll be getting a dash of sci-fi action
in there somewhere maybe so what's
engaged kiss all about them well it
takes place in the modern floating
metropolis veyron city where shu leads
his mega life thankfully he's got these
two girls to keep things lively first up
is the doting kisada and the other is
ayano his former colleague who seems
quite rough around the edges when it
comes to dealing with him together these
three form a dynamic that ensures a lot
of slapstick comedy that's bound to
entertain us for weeks to come what
hooked me to this show personally is the
staff i've made it clear before that i'm
a fan of both segano and data live and
seeing the people who had a part in
those titles work together gives me a
sense of anticipation there's not much
detail revealed yet but i'll be eagerly
awaiting this show
how about a more traditional isakai now
then my isakai life is in fourth place
when one gets transported to another
world one rolls in the roulette of luck
you can either get the best powers that
will make you an overpowered god or you
can get saddled with an unorthodox set
of powers in the end it's really how you
make the most out of said powers right
we've seen the rise of heroes like na
fumi and hajime precisely because they
rose up above their handicaps in the
quest to become the world's strongest
that's similar to what yuji sano has to
go through saddled with the unfortunate
profession of a mere monster tamer he
finds himself behind in the race to
become the world's greatest adventurer
it would be a cruel joke if he was just
deterred by that and thanks to his nifty
powers he manages to get the hell for
some slimes and acquire a second class
sage armed with two sets of skills that
could prove to be a winning combination
it's sano's turn to take over the world
power fantasy of the season here we go
it has a clear niche and with how
popular isakai still is these days it
will surely get an audience which is why
i placed it high on this list somehow
though the plot reminds me a bit of by
the grace of the gods and if you're a
sucker for these kinds of overcoming the
odds isaikai then you're gonna be in for
a treat
for gamers here's a treat for you
cyberpunk's coming in anime form with
cyberpunk edgerunners
[Music]
netflix is at it again with their
contribution to the popular cyberpunk
universe we knew it was only a matter of
time before the hit video game cyberpunk
2077 would get some sort of anime
representation and that time is now
instead of adapting the game into anime
format however cyberpunk edge runners
instead tell us of a standalone story
set in the game's universe we don't know
much about it yet but from the trailer
it seems to be a story of grit and guts
survival featuring our protagonist who
takes us on an adventure from the city
of the future all the way to outer space
we don't know much besides what the
trailers show but it's already looking
visually stunning as expected from
trigger let's see what other surprises
the guys have up their sleeves in their
own element sci-fi backdrop a plot that
can go absolutely off the rails in a
good way and a space setting looks like
trigger found the perfect ip for the
team if you've played cyberpunk 2077 or
are one of the people who are really
into this kind of sci-fi aesthetic then
you might want to give this a shot marky
calendars september 2022 is the release
lucifer the biscuit hammer comes in
second place
oh no the world is threatened and is
nearing destruction by the hands of a
giant mallet that can't be right can it
but that's just the world yuhi amamiya
finds himself in thankfully he's been
granted the powers to change the fate of
earth by harnessing the power of the
beast knight he must come together with
the other beast knights and the princess
to defeat the mage responsible for the
giant mallet however there's more to the
princess than meets the eye after all
she has some devious intentions of her
own she wants to save the world so that
she can destroy it herself
lucifer and the biscuit hammer was quite
the hit back in the 2000s and it's
surprising it took this long to get an
adaptation better late than never though
they say and i'm happy that you'll be
getting a chance to see this fun battle
manga in anime form it starts off quirky
before coming into its own eventually
showing you that you shouldn't judge a
story by its cover it's not too long so
you can get a head start by reading the
manga now
and finally we have call of the night
in a lot of ways yamari is just like us
he strives hard to maintain a cool
facade being good at studies and being
friends with a lot of people but doesn't
that kind of living get tiring after a
while well he certainly thinks so and he
just says screw it one day letting go of
everything and developing insomnia as a
result however he never found true
freedom that much can be said according
to the mysterious nazuna who invites him
into her apartment it's then that she
reveals her true identity as the vampire
guild takes a big bite in his neck
despite the premise giving some
monogatari vibes call of the night is
mostly a surprisingly wholesome slice of
life in that regard it's more bunny girl
sent by if i were to give a quick
comparison it's much more of a feel-good
story of the two and their growing bond
helped largely by their shared interest
in exploring the night being a comfy
series with a dash of mystery and action
here and there makes me see a lot of
potential in this anime to become a
seasonal blockbuster coming from the guy
who brought us dagashi kashi i've got a
lot of hopes for this anime
and that's it those are what i think are
the most anticipated new anime this
summer looking like a pretty decent
season don't you think so how does your
list compare to mine if you've enjoyed
the video don't forget to drop a like
and check out the channel's various
social media discord patreon and
instagram all have links in the
description box you can also check my
second channel vinitube kai for more
videos tailored to specific series oh
and video essays are on there too once
again thanks for watching and hope to
see you in the next one bye